we all know this famous photograph but
could you tell us a little bit about
what what got the idea started to to
tell this story as a feature film well
Holly and I one night we were at a party
of a friend of our Scott Feldman who was
an agent or still is an agent actually
we were ever at his house and we were we
were he just moved in and he was showing
us some paintings that that he had and
one of them was a really cool wine of
bum I think it was Steve McQueen Steve
McQueen that was done by a local artist
called Russell young and we both loved
it and and so I said to him later on
because we worked together where did you
get the painting from he goes oh yeah
here's the gallery this is where you can
get it from and so we went to have a
look and we ended up buying to a yellow
Sid Vicious and a pink Elvis Presley and
the the series that he'd done was a
series of famous of five famous
celebrities of famous they're also
famous five celebrities and they were
done in five different colors so there
were 25 paintings and we got a yellow a
pink Elvis as I said and they were mug
shots and and a couple years later we
were having Christmas party at a tour
has and a friend of mine called Jerry
Siegel who's a longtime friend who on
the side is kind of an Elvis
impersonator and he's actually the Elvis
impersonator in the movie when the
airport yeah and he I said to him Joey
you know there's something fascinating
about this Elvis picture and I just
can't I can't you know I keep thinking
about it how did the cops how do you
manage to keep because it was a picture
of him with the long hair like in this
and the gold chains on the land and the
rings and the aviator glasses and the
big collar white collar and I said how
come they kept the cops let him keep his
sunglasses aren't for the shot he goes
that's not a mugshot I go what are you
talking about you guys know that's not a
mugshot I go whitewater well what is it
he goes you don't know that story I go
what are you talking about he goes yeah
that's when Elvis became under grow
under cover drug agent I go he became
what and he goes yeah and that's when he
went undercover
uh I said well are you kidding you guys
know you don't know the whole story you
know he showed up at the White House of
Christmas in 1970 demanded a meeting
with elvia with President Nixon and he
managed to get in there and he taught
Nixon into making him an undercover drug
agent and as I come on and then the next
day I was looking on the computer and
checking the story out and just kept
sitting with me and and then I thought
this is a movie I gotta make this as a
movie well and then the I mean if you're
making a movie where the two main
characters are iconic people like elvis
presley at richard nixon casting the
movie is I mean that's going to possibly
mean the difference between life and
death so Holly could you talk a little
bit about how this really was cast well
there was two incarnations of the movie
at one point we were going to make the
movie like four years ago i think it was
and eric bana was going to originally be
um elvis presley and i had been sending
i sent the script to Michael Shannon's
managers like that I love Michael
Michael and I did a movie together 10
years ago and said we have to put
Michael in the movie somewhere he's one
of the best actors we have to do
something he wasn't really available at
that time so then when the movie fell
apart we like we put it away in a drawer
and I think that everyone cried for a
couple of months and you know didn't
want to bring it back out for a while
and then I ran into Michael um at a New
York at a opening of a Broadway play a
friend of ours and I was kind of just
watching Michael and you know is that it
was a party late at night probably two
or three in the morning and how he was
standing then you know talking to people
and I was watching all of these actors
Tom Sturridge and Ben Foster and Alec
Baldwin and everyone was coming to
Michael you know they were coming up to
Michael and was there opening of their
play and talking to him about you know
he's their favorite actor oh you know
and you just kind of want it was
something like you've never seen before
you know it was the presence that he had
so that's when I started talking to him
about Elvis and it was a very very very
long process and then once once once he
got involved then we started talking
about who would be
person for Nixon and I have a long time
relationship with with Kevin stretching
back from when I was in Egypt with
Morrison my work with him I'm beyond the
sea which is you know his brilliant
thing that he did where he became
blanket Bobby Darin and you know he just
becomes when he plays a character he
just becomes that person and and I and
then we became obsessed with that idea
and and luckily he was actually
available it was part of his hiatus
right with that moment which from house
of cards and and he said you know I'll
give you five days and I was like okay
I'm you know he said I don't care how
you do it how you pull it off I'm going
to arrive on Monday morning I'll be
there at nine o'clock on the set and on
Friday night at six at 6pm I will be on
a check Jack going to London and what
you get is what you get I was like thank
you sir the movie is such an interesting
balance of kind of absurd humor and real
drama I mean real dramatic i mean that's
that's a very unique balance that's okay
funny too I don't think people think of
him as funny but um want you to know him
like he has the driest sickest sense of
humor he's you know he's the he's the
best at telling a joke and um yeah I
realize he do super Elvis you know Elvis
had that you know he you know Jerry
Schilling who was involved in this film
and who was Elvis's best friend and you
know he right away and he said no to sir
you know he definitely you know had an
impact and who was cast in the film and
he met Michael he you know right Oh
Isaac this guy can do it you know this
guy can do it and I think that's what
gave Michael the confidence and and
Jerry actually wrote a book about his
time with Elvis right and that was I
mean what were the since richard nixon
hand yet set up his recording equipment
in the Oval Office there is no recording
of Elvis and him actually a lot of
what's in here is really is actually
what happened and I think that of course
people say oh what really do they say
there's no recording equipment you know
what was actually the conversations but
but a lot of it really happened and I
think as we kind of went down through
the story and started and the square
decided to evolve and become the movie
that it eventually became we started
moving away from the kind of slapstick
comedy was like oh you know is this so
stupid Elvis and the White has tripping
over the phone and President Nixon and
we don't you know in the end we thought
about and thought that's not the classy
version of this movie and I think Jerry
actually drove us there on some bars on
some real basis actually and I think
there's a clue at the very beginning of
this movie when he's sitting in the in
his in his lair at Graceland and he's
watching all those different televisions
one of the clips is was Elvis's favorite
movie of all time and you see him smile
and give a wry smile that which is dr.
Strangelove and there's the funny moment
where he says no fighting in the war
room guys and and I think you know what
we were trying to do was kind of blend
that absurdist humor and me and make
this it's situational comedy where it's
so ridiculous that it's funny without
the act and the actors have to be
completely straight well and can you
talk tell us a little bit about how the
director Liza Johnson came to to work on
the film well it was it was um is
interesting because oh Cassian was
making him actually made a move on her
making a movie with her and that's when
i'm at her cuz i was in new orleans
making a film you know new islands it's
there's three or four movies and
everyone gets together and ends up the
same restaurants and stuff so everyone
kind of hangs out um so I met her and
really liked her and then hasn't been
making a movie with her and then when
you know Michael after two we waited two
years for Michael said was flirting with
it saying yes but oh I you know he had a
the HBO series so he wasn't available
and then he had him make nickels film
and there was always there was always
another film that he wanted to throw in
front of our big meeting he didn't have
to do it um though he just kept waiting
and so then when it got to stop speaking
about directors she's someone who had
come up and we all that it will we go
relationship she's great she did a movie
with Michael for the return which is her
first movie and was very good and so
then when Holly said to him Liza Johnson
is like oh yeah thank you both very much
for joining us this was a wonderful
conversation and thank you
so much for the film thank you